yeah and you were talking about how the
brain can actually over time adapt in
such fascinating ways depending on what
you're learning on this example there's
a there's this thing called the
knowledge and that is the like what is
it it's 24,000 streets and 50,000 places
of interest that a London taxi cab
driver has to memorize and they're
studying this like three to four hours
per day of just like reciting simulated
routes of them them having to drive and
when you look at their brain in
neuroimaging you can see that their
hippocampus is larger yeah exactly and
this in the census is is a cool example
and it's no surprise which is to say if
you dedicate yourself to a particular
task we can very often see physical
changes in the structure of your brain
just as an example if you take up
juggling I can see changes in your brain
if actually if I look at a brain I can
tell whether you are a piano player or a
violin player just because with a you
know with violin you're using detailed
hand motions with one hand but not the
other with a piano you're using both and
that causes changes in the motor cortex
that I can just look at and see so you
have really big architectural changes in
the brain based on what you do and of
course what your goals are and so on
there's some David when played against a
like a ten-year-old cup stacker yeah the
world champion world champion cup
stacker and and it's so fascinating how
the neuro neuro imaging on the on the
ten-year-old cup stacker it was all
unconsciously going on there was
basically no neural signatures in his
brain while he was doing this and then
David was basically consciously trying
to figure out how to cup stack and and
his brain was just firing a crapload
trying to figure out how to mop too how
to maximize that and this is the general
story is that when you're consciously
attending to something you have to burn
a lot of energy to figure it out and
what the brain is always trying to do is
automatic things that you're doing over
and over and figure out how to burn it
into the circuitry of the brain so that
then you can do it you know quickly and
efficiently